we're live we're live good morning good
afternoon good evening wherever the hell
you are in the world and welcome to
citric your Sci-Fi TV movie channel
and that's your that's your turn hello
I'm Mike I'm obviously uh the runner of
Co Cloud where my channel features loads
of pranks comedy and also the solo on
sci-fi podcast and it's nice to be with
you Jay how are you doing all right I am
very well sir bit time good good are you
long day at work lots of work at the
moment but anyway hey Sarah hey Trevor
how are you doing right so we are going
to be doing a little bit of a series of
of videos aren't we where we're going to
review all of the Star Trek movies every
movie has quite a few movies to go
through but it's gonna be fun it's gonna
be interesting lot of content out there
well yeah one or two of them I'm looking
forward to one or two of them not so
much but it's Star Trek so it's and it's
still good um and as a Star Trek fan we
can break them
down and get into the minua of it but um
but yeah a couple of these films are
going to be painful to review but we are
starting um the slow picture is a very
good way of poting this because we are
gonna hey Davey how you doing um we are
gonna be talking first about Star Trek
motion picture so shall I just tell us
how we're going to be rating please do
please do explain it so I need I need to
get my photo that I sent you earli
because I'll forget how we do I've got
it here as well for reference right so
we have the Kirk rating which is rating
the action the excitement yeah of the
story how much we enjoy you know the the
action sequences Etc we have the Spock
rating does the story make sense is it
logical even in even in the motion
picture we're GNA
[Laughter]
be we have the check off rating um the
Star Trek values those values that we
think of Star Trek I mean because I
that's the check off rating because he
was a Russian guy during the Cold War I
think that's the epitome of the the Trek
values the bones rating is there humor
in the in the film or is it funny
because bones always crack me up yes U
the Scotty rating technology and science
does the technology and the science is
interesting is there something in there
that we like is there the designs
anything like that okay the rating how
well is it
written um because she's into languages
see what I've done here it's so oh it's
very very clever the way you sort of
comp it together that's good and the
last one is the most subtle it's the
seven of nine rating for visuals of how
the movie looks because Jerry Ryan is
the prettiest lady
the ier Nicole deor myself as entry but
there we go well there you go but I I
love seven so anybody she's right she's
lovely she's very nice yeah yeah you
will all get banned from the channel and
then overall we're going to take all of
those scores we're going to divide them
by I think they're seven eight we're
going to divide them by eight and that
gives us the overall gan
sure okay well I'm I'm old enough to
remember actually going to see it when
it was come out in
1979 uh I think I was living in
Northampton at the time either I just
come back to London um and um I went to
see it with my mom my nan and my uncle
and uh I was a huge huge fan of Star
Trek even though I was young so this was
the first time they were back I mean
they were back the first time since
before I was born at the time and um I
will say that my family's reactions were
that my n fell as sleep um and um I
don't think my UNC was that impressed
because he just seen Star Wars about two
years before and my mom wasn't a big
sci-fi fan so for their perspective it
wasn't very good I for one um I liked
the fact that uh you know it was then
back out there and it was an update um
but of course um the the first thing
which all the people are really saying
is it was the pacing that was the the
factor which was the most negative
factor straight away so how about you
what did you think about it when you
first saw it um I hated it did you
really I'm not joking it wasn't the
first Star Trek movie I ever watched oh
okay so you I'm a little bit younger
than yourself yes um so I was one when
this film came out um uh so I would have
watched The Wrath of Khan first and
loved it um the first movie I remember
coming out is the Undiscovered Country
and I adore 1991 that was yeah yeah but
TNG was was already out by then so I was
already a big tngg fan by then so um so
yeah I when I did watch
it I have to admit yeah the pacing I'm I
am watching it going what the hell were
they thinking and I know what they were
thinking they were thinking
2001 you gonna say that yeah they were
were yeah and people liked that so let's
make that um and Star Wars and let's
going to forget the Star Wars pacing
isn't exactly 100 miles an hour either I
find the Star Wars movies I know this is
I I I get stick for this I don't like
the original Star Wars movies
particularly um they're all right don't
get me wrong I enjoy them I enjoy I
enjoy the visuals of Star Wars and the
lightsabers but I find them a bit slow
and I find them a bit boring but when
they came out at the time they were they
were the biggest thing ever because
nothing have been like that for that
particular aspect in science fiction and
I think that's why it gives you you know
you seen God have many films since then
so you know you got more of a reference
for other movies you know what I mean I
just think there was certain iconic
parts of the Star Wars film that that
that Ben anyway we're not talking about
the Star Wars film no no no no but so
for me yeah the the motion picture is is
the boring Star Trek
film um and we're gonna when we start
breaking this down so we'll go into the
Kirk rating straight away all right
because it is very slow we're rting all
of these out of five by the way so it's
all the score five each one so for me
I've rated
it I've rate it as a two right and the
only reason it's getting a two not a one
because initially it was a one and I
went and M it over it's very slow but I
do love the kingon scene you gonna say
that that is exactly what I was going to
say as well the first 10 minutes of the
movie is excellent with the future cloud
and the the Clinging On to the first
time we've ever seen them updated since
the move the actual toos and it's an
awesome scene it's really really good
and thing is the problem is that once
you see that you think oh this is gonna
be something spectacular and then after
that when you finally see Kirk in the
Enterprise and going to visia that's
when it lets it down and that's a shame
but as you say it's definitely worth an
extra point because of that opening
thing I if I could have done 1. five I
decided I wouldn't do that so all right
we can't do that all right okay um I
mean I mean we can but then it it makes
no let's just just Let's Do It um so I I
rounded up a little bit so I gave it a
two i' a couple of my scores are rounded
up a little bit all right I feel I'm
being that's a kind
to I'm also going to give it a two um
are we going to do all yours the whole
thing through are we going to just do
each one first of all so we're do like
the Kirk racing back and forth or how
we'll do the Kirk back and forth and
then we'll yeah we'll go through them
back and forth get confusing so yeah all
right well I'm actually going to give it
a two as well for the exactly the same
reasons that you are um but um like I
said that that opening scene was pretty
impressive um I mean there wasn't you
know in the Vega Cloud there's one or
two scenes where it was just basically
flying over the Visa cloud and finally
getting to the center of it which was
about an hour of them staring at the
screen and that's that's not high in
action is it I just stood looking at the
screen I remember suu
going beautiful visuals which we go back
to in another rating later on but as you
say no it was a bit slow very
slow I watched this today and I went to
the toilet twice during I've got a big
cup of tea and I watched it this morning
so I like a pint of tea
okay um but sci-fi Quest I'm blocking
you from the channel that's the last
time you mock me boy the last
time no
not he knows I'm not he knows I'm only
kidding um but yeah I it this is not an
exciting fun movie by any stretch of the
imagination this was a movie I think
Paramount genuinely thought we could win
an Oscar and they were never going to
win an Oscar I think they wanted it to
be sort of deep and philosophical that's
that's what they were trying to do they
were trying to make it something which
didn't fit in with the original uh TV
show and I think that's half the problem
with why it went wrong yeah I don't get
me wrong it's a I like no I was going to
say it's a good film but I like it I
don't it's not a bad film it isn't it's
a boring
film so welcome to the review
I mean that's it that's the end of it we
could sort of like just finish off with
just saying it's a boring film
see this will be a short one because
it's not loow St know the one thing I um
think is I did I've forgotten about you
know cck off at one point gets badly
burned the um the weapon hits the shield
H yeah like y God the the writers really
hate check off in the next film he's got
a worm going in his ear yeah and think
what checkov do he just like leave him
alone
because he a new he was the youngest one
to join the cast or the actual one that
start joined the original show later in
season two so maybe they just thought
because he was the I think there's a
[__] up in continuity isn't there is
we're going to talk about R of K yeah
yeah yeah he shouldn't have met him no
he shouldn't have met him um but anyway
we'll talk about the logic of that so
the Spock rating right now this is I'm
gonna go on for a bit now go on oh
there's going to be ranting so logic
okay V
is a spaceship with a massive freaking
Cloud around it right why don't know no
reason no sense no reason no reason is
enormous as well the energy Cloud that
surrounds V is 82 or is that a five oh
82 astronomical units wide and if you
don't know lovely people the
astronomical unit is the distance
between the Sun and the Earth okay right
and I think it's about N9 n million
miles yes I
know 8.9 yeah so um this thing was
enormous I mean enormous that's what she
said yeah sorry
um
hey it'll never
fit it it just and right yeah the
Enterprise was going to take 20 hours at
warp 7even to get there and the cloud
was three days away MH so how fast was
that cloud
traveling Oh this is maths now maths is
not one of my strong points it must have
been traveling at
warp I think it was traveling warp
although yeah I think so but we saw it
it looked like it was traveling impulse
though yeah it looked like it was
slowly it slowed down when it saw
something coming in front of it or
something all right I know that's
stretch I'm just saying yeah but I've
never seen an energy a cloud that big
travel at War but no so that's
nonsense um The Wormhole scene utter
nonsense they basically just went Jane
Roden B I think did this a little bit
occasionally and he'd went wormholes are
a thing in science
excellent okay well the engines are
going to be disbalanced and we're going
to create a wormhole why because it's
sound
sciency and it's it's
not um so it was supposed to be an
instability in the war drive or
something which is what unbalanced and
then Spock had to come and fix it had to
yeah and then there was an asteroid in
the middle of it or something as well
yeah an asteroid got dragged into the
Wormhole um so again unless that's just
a term they used to describe the the
imbalance and the problem but it's not a
wormhole that is just something that had
been theorized in science and they just
went
Wormhole and and that irritates me um so
both of those things there was no logic
to my final issue that I have there's no
logic to how come V was so
technologically advanced Way Beyond
everything
that's um Way Beyond um any science we
had but they didn't know about
dirt because all they had to do was
clean and the um the the Voyager thing
off and they'd have known it was called
Voyager not veger they dirt was beyond
them they had no clue and that I just
I'm watching that going just clean it
and then but anyway that's not really a
logical thing that was just irritated me
it's just yeah it's just a fact which is
irritating in the movie I think yeah
well I found um oh the other thing was
Voyager I mean Star Trek is 300 years
ahead I think uh 23rd yeah 22
228s so Voyager would be nowhere near
that far away it would it wouldn't have
even made the next star system so again
from a um reality point of view Voyager
voyagers only just left our solar system
no actually actually it said and this
doesn't make sense either that they
thought that Voyager 6 had actually
disappeared in a black in a black went
through a wormhole or something no a
black hole black hole which again that's
not how black holes work it's squish
yeah it's not right so um so it's shot
it over the other side of the Galaxy but
yeah no no sense doesn't make sense um
how about you I'm soor I've I've s I've
given it a two but I'll come back to why
I've given it a two in a
second um I've just bitched for five
minutes I've got some positives no no no
no it's fine I think that for The
Logical storyline I mean um I I think
for me yeah I probably would give it a
2.5 but we're not going to do that
but I'd rather not give it a three I'd
probably give it a two like Q um I I I
think that you know one thing in Star
Trek and and anything in science fiction
is to a degree you have to kind of just
sometimes Just Go With It there are some
strange ideas which um they use in order
to make a story work and they don't
always do that they don't always work um
I think really I mean you've already
said most of the things I'm trying to
think of any other um inaccuracies I can
think of but I think the I think you've
already said basically the the factors
of um what what do work and what don't
don't work another thing which was a bit
weird was the IAH thing where um she was
kind of like almost like assimilated
into the
v um memory assimilate what was that
well no yeah but there's a link I know
what you yeah and I know you know about
this as well there might be a link we'll
come back to a bit later because it's a
very interesting possibility yes but why
was why was she taken into VI's memory
why was she absorbed what was point of
that was that just to learn more about
Humanity because they were SE seeking
the Creator on Earth and of course IAH
wasn't even human anyway she was Delton
um I suppose that's not really I don't
know I just don't know whether some of
these things were actually necessary for
the movie I don't know it's a bit a
weird well when we talk about the
writing the first thing aah says
um my celibacy is well documented oh
yeah that was such
a I didn't ask about that love calm down
yeah I know yeah exactly it's like why
so Random it was so Random I know
relevant to thing but that that was that
stood out like a s film and again not
logical it was no sense for the story um
positives I love the Enterprise
refit one of the best one of the best
versions out there in Star Trek I think
of an enterpr from a logic point of view
I'm going to say that the things like
the um cargo
bay really good the way they set it up
with the cargo ships sort of coming in
and depositing things and stuff and the
way they they laid it all out is better
than they do nowadays to be honest the
Enterprise in strange new Worlds the way
they've set the cargo bay up at the back
there it doesn't work it doesn't work
the Enterprise of that show is much much
bigger this Enterprise really did follow
on from the to Enterprise
I thought it I thought it was a
wonderful continuation of the actual um
of the TV show which um unfortunately
the new show hasn't really done
logically I know we not about that but I
just love the look of it as well I did
like the I did like the uniforms the
uniforms weren't good in there I also
liked how they did have uniforms and
dress from the series as well if you
actually look when he when Kirk first
drives at the base some of them are
wearing like the toga outfits and things
people in the background sort of thing
and then there's the one that's like the
military uniform which um one of them
wears when they play um when they do
like that um they do a fight scene oh
yeah yeah yeah so the security Star Trek
Star Star Trek security s thing um so I
I I thought that was really good how
they dragged that in from the series but
again updated everything made everything
so it wasn't too you know it's it worked
I love Bon's outfit I love his belt I
want his belt buckle um but the warp
engine was where I was going to go this
is the first time we get to see the warp
engine proper warp core formulated like
that that stuck through and again we'll
talk about this when we talk about the
technology and and the visuals and
things this film set up Star Trek for
the next 40 years until JJ abrs come
along and Tred to undo it um the visuals
and the the style and the logic of how a
warp engine works you know it was really
thought out yeah and I know Rod andury
actually got to build an engine that he
thought it needed to look more
mechanical than what they had before
because they didn't have the technology
they didn't have the the the time to
build a big set sort of thing and and as
you say a lot of the sets in this this
movie were continued in one form or
another through a lot of the 24th
century Star Trek shows 20 years later
you know next Generation took on a lot
of the sets Voyager took on the War uh
the engineering warness warp core so
things like so as you say it was a very
important step in the look of Star Trek
for decades to come afterwards which was
one of its biggest positives I think and
they did it really well and they made I
I just thought they made changes that
again because we're talking about the
spot rting there was things that were
logical that they did they really
thought through and and that's why they
stuck I think because they made sense
they made more sense it was more
mechanical more more like an engine you
know it so yeah there's a lot of things
that made sense um the whole transporter
SE quence again it was oh the transport
sport uh malfunction sequence where the
Vulcan just uh that was really quite
creepy it was and he hear sort of scream
as he and uh what we got back didn't
live for long thank goodness or
something like that because
it yeah that was pretty creepy I like
that as a scene because it fit the whole
thing of the Enterprise isn't ready it
was a very too early to go out it's not
ready yeah a physical way of going this
we're not ready yeah um I really like
that um and because the Enterprise
Transporters weren't working though
that's why he had to do the long shuttle
scene yes the very long shuttle
scene very long but it's got a lovely
musical score by Jerry Goldsmith the
music is
wonderful it's know then but you know
what I mean yeah yeah but it's it's just
too too long you know whereas uh other
shows more recent shows like Discovery
you hardly ever seen exterior shot of
the discovery and I like a good exterior
but it was a bit too much out the way it
was way too no it was it was just three
hours too long and that was the problem
how long is the running time of it
actually 72 weeks 72 weeks okay no just
over two hours it doesn't two hours yes
I think it's two I thought it was about
hours tell us it's 2 hours and like a
minute or 2 hours and 10 minutes that
seems like a long two hours it seems
like a long it's a long two hours yes um
okay then so we' both scored that a two
again so the check off rating so this is
the rating that we say does this film
fulfill sort of star treking I just made
a new word up start trekking
values yeah let's go with start trekking
it's a
thing sort
of I I I struggle with this one a little
bit because yes
exploration the unknown that's what I'm
thinking of
yeah entity and explor yeah something
unknown how to deal with it how how a
difference in humanity that's a lot of
star trep values the king gon rocked up
and shot at it no idea know yeah they
would do that they cling on so I mean
that's fine that that works and then
they want oh run away that didn't work
why didn't they go to walk the the
energy thing is coming towards it and
the Clinger ship goes wait wait I was wa
waiting to um burst into that K-pop
thing and like oh yeah um and wait fire
and I'm like no wait wait go to war
no um but it doesn't Stanley says it's
two out of 10 I knew there's a one in it
thank you very much Stanley okay all
right um so I noticed that today it was
one of the things I looked at how long
is this film because it feels much
longer um 2 hours 10 um the REM and the
credits gone for about 20 minutes so
um but there isn't anything more than
that though there is the exploration
there is the understanding let's let's
not fire first let's talk to the threat
let's find out what's going on um so let
me ask you what do you think was missing
what do you think in respect of that
they they should have maybe might bring
up some more points as to what was
missing from that I don't think there's
nothing necessarily missing this was the
story it was about exploration it was
about you know wonder and um and like
say understanding of a of an alien being
and trying something that is completely
alien like to the point where they
didn't even you know it was trying to
send those messages and they didn't even
know because it was so far beyond them
so yeah beyond what they could yeah so
that is very star trekking but for me
there was there was maybe
lacking a layers to it in that you know
there was no the the best thing about
Star Trek is that they can talk about
real um problems in our society racism
sexism all these things um but they can
use the metaphor of sci-fi to sort of
make yes they can which is what it's all
about yes not sh down your throat sort
of thing it makes you think I'm not sure
this film has those sort of layers to it
I don't think there a lot of hidden
meaning basically it was basically what
you see is what you get yeah
yeah
so yeah it's it's it's I've given it a
three because I think it's there but it
doesn't go as far as I think other Star
Trek
does you
know well I'm going to give it a two
just to be slightly different I think
okay because I I agree with what you're
saying and you know there's been so many
different examples where as you say you
know and it goes back to you know the
ideas of sexism and racism and all the
different factors which Star Trek always
did in the original series but it did it
in a hidden way to avoid senses and
things like that as you say this movie
was basically it was a gen genetic
generic alien entity coming to Earth
they need to stop it they need to
understand why so um and that's what it
did and they did it in a very very slow
way so I'll I'll give it to on that one
I think could they should have rename it
Star Trek
snail um picture as well isn't it the
slow motion picture and all sorts of
those been going around for years you
know that's one problem with the actual
movie it's always had nicknames this is
a straightforward one now because we'll
um the the bones rating is there any
humor is it funny is it interesting
and no I'm trying to think of funny
scenes in it um there isn't any I've
given I like I like it when mcoy says
he's I think they said he says they
drafted me or something and he was
actually yeah he got drafted
again bone and say are there any casual
yes my wits as in at my Wit's End um and
but again it's it's bones being bones
actually bones is the only character
that brings any like he says to spar oh
my so l so help me I'm actually pleased
to see you or something and Spock sort
of gives his sort of like raises his
eyebrow and yeah is all based on McCoy
if McCoy hadn't been in the movie there
literally wouldn't have been the funnest
scene at all it would have been a zero
if McCoy except for those McCoy teams
and they're not they're just McCoy being
McCoy um so that's there was a nice
scene where Scotty talks to Kirk and uh
they said um he says oh they gave me
back the Enterprise and he goes
um Amon neora I'm surprised he he let
you do that and he he you're
right accent back yeah I quite like that
scene but that's a very very small
that's like a 5sec bit of
it's all done very dead pan it's all
done
very serious and Star Trek don't get me
wrong Star Trek isn't hilarious Star
Trek is never really it's not like the
oral or something is it no no when it
tries to be funny generally it doesn't
do a very good job but it is
entertaining it is a bit tongue and
cheek sometimes it is a
bit um you know uh light-hearted or
whatever in places and this film just
doesn't have any of that no and that's
something which is really missing in the
movie that's definitely something which
is really missing um what's your score
oh it'll have to be a one afraid sorry
it'll have to be a one how about yours
one yeah okay it wasn't from McCoy it
would been a zero yeah I can't knock
Point minus
one that's not the scoring system is it
no yeah well that's why we got bones is
the rating because he's hilarious he
just that's yeah that's a good idea that
works the Scotty rating right so
technology
um just the the the science anything
like this we've already we've already
touched on a few the things I'm going to
talk about negatively the Wormhole thing
made no
sense um the cloud made no
sense um the Veer going Voyager going
through a black hole
no um but positives again the redesign
is amazing the warp core is amazing um I
love the kingon warships are amazing I
loved how they did things
like um putting the um phases through
the warp core now to increase power so
you couldn't use the phases well when
because of the instability you had to
use the photon torpedo even the photon
Torpedoes were blue which was weird but
I let they used be orange didn't they I
think orange I think orange in the
second one they're orange and ra KH
they're orange again yeah so they look
weird as blue um but for me
me I've given it a three because of the
warp engines and the redesign of the
Enterprise mainly and the and the look
of the ship um there were so many other
like technically inaccurate things in
this movie that were was just odd um the
cloud being the main one makes no sense
at all that I just can't get my head
round on why on Earth a ship would
surround itself with such a massive
energy field for no reason
um you know but anyway you think yeah um
I think I hate to sound repetitious but
I probably give it a three as well and
the main factors for the three would be
at least the technological side of with
this is the star Fleet and going back to
what we said earlier on this is the side
side of things you're going to see for a
long time you see the star base where
the Enterprise leaves when the actual
shutle grass goes to the Enterprise um
and again you know it's very important
at least for Canon in how St Star Trek
like I said before it's never it would
never be the same after the motion
picture comes out um it's it can't be
more than three again because of what
we've already said um the vaa situation
was a bit dared um I also like the fact
that we saw proper Klingons Interiors
the interior of the Klingon ship that's
pretty much similar to how it always is
the first time we hear on language which
was actually created started from this
movie um um and um you see cling on the
actual writing on the actual
consoles um also the sound effects are
great the photon Torpedoes coming out
that was a sound effect they use motion
Next Generation Um so yeah it's going to
be a three but it's a three for the
technological side of things not so much
the actual things like U when Kirk
arrives at staff based command he goes
on he arrives on a shuttle and he
arrives in what looks like a train
station things like that like a rail
isn't it it's all land yeah um I liked
things like that and I thought the
technology looked very cool there um I
liked things how they like talked about
the engines being
unbalanced and that could again it cause
a wormhole which is stupid but the fact
that it would cause a problem I thought
was very
clever there's there's lots of things
there that were really clever it's just
that there was also some silly things
that that that's why it loses marks for
me okay right the
writing that one stupid line that we've
already mentioned was
ridiculous
um it's a it's an hourong movie that
they stretched over two hours
somehow but actually I don't have a
problem with the
writing I I actually think on the whole
it's very good it but wasn't it actually
the actual writing for this movie uh
based on the episode original series The
Changeling with Nomad which was a probe
had a very similar as very similar story
idea yeah so I know I know obviously
it's not the same thing but um do you
wish that they' have created a story
line which really wasn't at least for
what it appears quite heavily influenced
on the original series episode with the
with the
NAD see the problem is star Trekkers
well and most series to be fair they've
always done on that almost all of the
movies you can point to an episode
somewhere and go it's a bit similar to
that yeah yeah that's a fair point that
is a fair point some of the new movies
how many times have they remade Wrath of
car now actually my video tomorrow is is
he's actually talking about how St Into
Darkness was a remake of it and and it's
in the same you straight up remake and
um and actually Nemesis really Nemesis
is almost a point too remake of RAF of
KH I had thought about that actually
it's I mean it's it's almost I mean
lower decks recently did it but it was
an omage it was a you know it was a a
parody almost of the ra he's identifying
it it's not just like pretending to be
different yeah I it's it's pointing it's
going Wrath of k
um but yeah there's a big argument
basically say every because rra of Khan
was so popular and such an iconic movie
that every other Star Trek film after
that the executives will go in who's the
who's KH where's the KH in this movie
and um expect it similar to the next
movie yeah because it was such an iconic
fil say Ronald Mo was basically talking
about in a recent interview basically
saying it really limited creativity
because they kept pushing for that so um
so yeah that's that's that'll be
tomorrow's video if I get it edited it
very much depends on whether I get up in
the morning or not um or there won't be
a video
tomorrow okay um
but I'm I'm thinking from a um the the
the conversations in the in the thing
you know the um the way it's written the
way the characters interact with each
other it was all very on point for what
we should expect from the relationships
I thought Spock was a bit off um but I
think they were they did that on purpose
to sort of reset him in a way to make
him a bit more Vulcan again because he
started to sort of um become a little
bit more human in the series towards the
end he gone back to they had the ponar
didn't he is it not yeah was it P pushed
him back not Pon the um P far is the is
no what's the thing he went to he went
to uh Vulcan to have something done it
was
uh where they have the is it is it that
sounds right to me i' literally watch
call yeah somebody in the audience will
tell us somebody in one of the guys tell
us yeah so
um yeah I I I I generally thought the
characters and everything were written
really well I thought the overall
story was a bit stupid col sci-fi
question was col thank you I don't think
that's how you spell it but um but it's
near k k
sorry um I think I I I want to say
there's a h in it as well but I don't um
because they say it in Vulcan at the
start then they I remember seeing it
spelled out I was like
um it's all right I I I have no problems
with the way to written like I say the
overall storyline bit
weird
um I but but like I say the the
interactions between the crew is is the
main area there was nothing awkward
about it except for that one line that
was just weird
um uh the relationships I thought the
the the the captain Deca relationship
ask you I mean obviously on the ship we
had the regular cast but we also had
Deca and IIA how do you think do you
think they fitted in well with the old
cast do you think that worked quite well
I think they were put into to be taken
out think yeah um but but yeah I think
the whole thing about a new Captain Kirk
pushing his way back in I think that
really fit with the
character the Kirk we know and and we
come to know particularly that he's an
egomaniac in lots of ways um and that
showed and that that being a captain is
core to him sort of thing and when he
when he was promoted it just messed him
up we saw that through into Generations
you know telling C for the love of God
don't get out of the chair you know um
so yeah but I thought that it it it it
put in that Dynamic of somebody we
didn't know but it was done basically
write them straight back out again um
and then the core crew the only thing I
would say Czech off was very
underutilized in this
movie was very underutilized this movie
Aura was basically just there she just
said about five words didn't she Aur how
all um those crew developed way more in
the later movies they did absolutely
they were they were there was the they
were all much bigger Parts when they but
in this movie it's Spock bones Kirk
Deca and that's about it I suppose in
the original series the main obviously
three were Kirk Spar and McCoy and the
rest of the cast were literally the back
quite a lot not getting too involved and
I suppose they replicated that for the
movie I guess yeah and then then that
had to develop over time but you're
right Kirk and Spock with the Stars
basically in bones and then yeah the
rest of them um just developed yeah um I
mean Czech off was always just seen as
the kid when he I mean especially in the
first yeah season two and had a wig on
as well in the First episodes and he was
really he did he had a Beatles wig
apparently I think or like you know the
monkeys or something had like one of
those things I think his hair was too
short and he was um thing yeah and um
but he you know we didn't see a lot of
what his character progressed in the
original series that much really same
with Zulu you know it was only until as
you say the movies later on that their
characters fleshed out suu a couple of
times with the swords and the things and
and a couple of things but no not a
great deal no
um yeah um yeah like I said um I always
really like check off and is a is a is a
is a stupid kid sort of thing um so yeah
um i' I've given the writing a three
anyway because I don't think there's
anything offensive there's nothing
awkward when we get to the writing of
things like Star Trek
5 there are problems in the writing of
that even though I think that would be
low I think that'll be low for me there
are highs in that movie that I love um
but overall very different every movie
is different some have more humor some
have better pacing I'm gonna give it a
three as well I say this I have a
feeling I'm gonna really struggle with
Star Trek five just just as a side note
here you can three as well sorry I'll
write that down I'm going to struggle
with Star Trek 5 because there there are
some really really good bits in that
film it's just like like say the
national park bit was quite good but he
falls
down yeah yeah the whole bit where um
cbok is is putting them back into their
memories and stuff the bit with McCoy oh
and his dad yeah that was really good
really good yeah and actually you've got
the scene then goes um excuse me why why
does God need a [__] a star sh he funny
and there are bits in that film that are
that are quite
be much higher than this film and
consider that right way yeah well humor
is will be much higher um but yeah um
I'm going to struggle with that film
definitely but three three okay okay
right we we will talk about a few points
the film in a minute that we've already
been having some conversations about the
Bor so we're going to come back to that
in a second but we've got one more
rating oh this one's going to be a high
one for me you know what it is visuals
the seven of nine visuals does this film
look yeah it's high oh it's going to be
a I don't know whether to give it a four
or a five quite frankly um well I think
it's limited by its day so I I have yeah
I don't mind that I don't mind that I
give that the benefit of the doubt you
know what I mean yeah I think you have
to think of it yeah what was capable at
the time so I've given because some
aspects of it don't look great um
there's the one bit with the cling on oh
damn it I forgot the name of the battle
cruiser anyway but the weapons coming up
behind it and it starts lighting up the
the battle cruiser As It Gets Hit and
I'm thinking oh my God that's a good
shot it's katinger isn't it the katinger
class um and it's just such a good shot
the whole stuff with the
cloud it's all very visually pretty and
I think it would have looked amazing at
the cinema and and I've seen it at the
cinema to be fair it does look amazing
at the cinema um it's it just went on
for too damn long and it was too much
um 2001 Space Odyssey went on for ages
let's do that and then just just so
influenced by that so influenced by that
movie definitely some of the some of the
shots within the cloud were a bit weird
because it was s like well why is it
doing all those shapes and things what
what and I wasn't a massive fan of some
of that visuals
but even with the limitations of the day
my God it's a good-look film um
obviously the Enterprise design I mean
bu it's my favorite Enterprise when the
Enterprise leaves dry do space do I mean
it was one such a wonderful visual um so
yeah like I
said I mean I think the best shots as
you say some of the V stuff was
unfortunately the most recent time I
watched it it was the director's
remastered version so some of the
visuals been slightly updated although
most of the main visuals are still there
um but um I mean one of the visuals
which has been updated which looks a lot
better
was there's a scene near the end where
they actually come out of the Enterprise
on the hull and they walk across um to a
sort of Pathway to where V is the um the
remastered one the actual um primary
hole looks a lot lot better than the
original one it just didn't look right
looked made look a lot nicer yeah look
better um so I would love to see a
proper digitally remastered version
because some of the effects were very
limited by the day um when the um kingas
are being destroyed yeah that would look
so much cooler if they could you know re
redo it now with digital thing it would
look amazing but um they might do one
day you never know I mean they they do
tend to redo these things from time to
time they Star Wars so why not but um
but no I I've given this four out of
five I think it is
um
it giv it the benefit of the time that
that that that you know where it was set
and everything and the limits of the
technology in the late 7s is um I think
it might be one of the most visually
stunning of all the Star Trek um when
you take that into account um things
just like the internal though like the
the the the bridge it look great the um
the the cling ones and the way they
looked again this is all part of the
visuals for me and the yeah it is a
visual aspect of course redesign perfect
the the warp core we've already
mentioned
perfect um a lot of the um sort of
buttons and stuff when the and the
command consoles and stuff I was this is
what I was always looking at for all of
this and I just thought it's just oh
it's just spot on a bit more advanced
than the series but still manual buttons
and things it's just lovely progression
yeah they got it's absolutely Spa on for
me
yeah I couldn't quite go to a five
because there were some effects I think
they more because they just went on too
long really than they than they look bad
they didn't look bad they just went on
yeah
unnecessarily I think with with me I
think I I know I've been paralleling a
lot of your scores but I would probably
give it a four as well um the situation
is that I mean there's one there's one
visual which was really bad and it was
the first time we see the V probe it's
like a white line of energy that goes on
board the Enterprise and I think that's
the one that makes contact with Aliyah
and she disappears but when they did it
because it was like a split screen the
actual Enterprise Bridge it doesn't mesh
the pan across screens it looks like the
actual um Bridges being squished
together it's a weird visual um which I
I I always remember there was a really
off and I always thought of something
like um like other big movies at the
time where it just stood out as a really
bad effect um again some of the V shots
um it didn't always make sense because I
just say it was a lot of it looks great
but it was it was too much
um so yeah I'll give it a four as well
so to be paring what
you I I didn't see the original release
brain because I'm only 45 I was one
years
old um but when Star Trek um first
Contact came out um there was a Treon
basically at Cinema they showed all of
the Star Treks back toback
overnight um and I got to see it then so
I got to see all of them back oh that
must that must have been quite a long
time to go through all those movies
though but oh about four o'clock in the
morning we hit Star Trek 5 and
I um and yeah um but but know amazing
and then we had breakfast and then um
because they they put on a big breakfast
for us all and then we um we got to see
um the premiere basically of Star Trek
first Contact wow and it was amazing
amazing no was huge when they came out
that um because it was a little bit
before the internet wasn't it we didn't
we didn't know what the Enterprise
looked like we didn't
know when The Sovereign came into shot
and they did that beautiful panning shot
there was an audible gasp like literally
really I for a British person to
go like we were buzzing
anyway so the
Rodenburg to talk about the Bor okay um
my
Rodenburg okay not massively high score
in moving no I love the way you work it
out though from the stats though that's
quite good and we'll obviously keep that
for each week I like that that's good I
will be tweeting that out and we will I
will definitely keep all of that so next
time in three or four weeks or whatever
when we do this when we do Wrath of KH I
feel WRA of KH might be slightly higher
scoring it will be higher it will be it
will be so yeah right the
Bor so there is a lot of rumors or fan
theory that V is related to the Borg
somehow yes I mean you use the word
assimilated earlier because that's what
they to Alia do you think well for one
the theory is either that the Bor
created V veger is the Borg from an
early reincarnation or the version of
the theory I like is that via created
the
Bor what do you think of that as fan
Theory do you think it holds
water well I mean we know that there was
a very technologically advanced World
which uh encountered the V
probe um at least that was actually said
in the movie so um whether this was the
Borg or it could have been an offshoot
of the Borg that assimilated the V probe
and learned about Humanity I'd like to
think there was a connection of some
sort I don't think it'll be as direct as
they are specifically v v is a borg
Remnant but I think it has some links
because we know that the V probe like
we've already said it went into a black
hole to another part of the Galaxy I
know black holes aren't supposed to do
that but that's what they said um so
it's possible that it went to a part of
the Delta quadrant or something where
the B first evolved and of course it
could be that the Bor have had um sort
of periods in time in the past where
they started to evolve to a point and
then it just sort of stopped or it went
off a separate Direction you know we we
we've seen the Bor of course they were
completely done to death in Voyer but
you know they've been around for
thousands of centuries it could well be
that there's some aspect of it I would I
would like to think there is some link
somewhere to Via or who does actually
know how old the Borg are I don't think
G says that they've evolved over
thousands of centuries she does doesn't
she actually and know that they wiped
out her her
racean y about the same time as well not
long
after 200 years I think it was
Generations so that wouldn't have been
long after this film is set basically
about 20 years after this so um I've
always wondered whether this was that
the Borg might have been C well look we
see them do this basically we see what
they do to Aliyah um she assimilated
said that yeah yeah I do wonder whether
they might have done that before and
then just left their experiment to go as
maybe it was a science experiment maybe
it was it could be that IAH was a
catalist and they orally created a b
Queen based on the fact that entity of
like that and a female kind of I know
I'm stretching but it's it's fun to
think about ideas about how it could
have been referenced from the motion
picture in some um Archer did meet the
Borg um but it was um that was connected
to time trouble that's a Time trouble
the B had gone back in time yeah yeah
yeah um but even then though actually
those Borg are then trying to
communicate with the Borg existing the
quadrant yes they are so if V did create
the Bor they'd already done it by this
point um and let them loose but um but
yeah it could have been something that V
did to try to understand or it could be
the V
isn't unique you know we we because we
never we don't really know what V right
V seems to be a living machine yes in
case which wants to evolve to something
more which wants to evolve to something
more it's it's the Bor it's an early
version of the Borg and we don't know
that that might have been the
original um Borg thing that that had
existed and still exists today
if if the Bor actually aren't linked up
then let's just ask are you surprised if
they hadn't gone that direction that V
or aspect of this have never come back
in Star Trek ever since in any shape or
form unless it is the Borg there is
another fan Theory actually that um V is
back in the comic books you know the new
God Wars comic books in I think V is one
of the characters in that and actually
come back but but yeah I mean I've
always wondered though like are the um
the the the all belong they know oblong
the um this the thing with the golf ball
that sticks out the bottom from oh the
world probe the world probe yeah yeah we
never see that again no we don't um that
that was never explained like who the
bloody hell was that um 200 years later
and we still have no clue um you know
it's like so yeah there are things like
that but I think once they've done with
things like that with Star Trek they
just they're just done a they um you
think something that
enormous and fast apparently it's really
really quick um that that they you know
by then you you you'd spot
them thought so yeah yeah yeah freaking
massive um I I I think they're the Bor I
I think this was an early Bor it
wouldn't even surprise me if this is
species one or species two or something
you know but
um the i' love I'd love that I mean do
you think that it will ever be answered
in any sort of future um movie or TV
show do you think it's always going to
be the mystery that a lot of people do
suspect it is the Borg but we never got
any concrete proof it was no we we'll
never get it confirmed I just think V
was probably built by speci because some
point the Bor would have
been um more
human I wonder if they built fure as a
living
machine um it's part of their
progression you know it's part of their
Evolution sort of thing um it might have
even been a weapon that then just sort
of became self-aware and sort of went
I'm gonna go for a Wanda or maybe it was
a weapon that then came in contact with
v yeah and Voyager sorry and sort of
went and absorbed it and sort of went ah
and and and and went out to it Mission
sort of thing because it would have took
potentially hundreds of you it would
have took 100 years or so to get to our
quadrant um but it been great to see a
very a time travel episode where the Bor
were very very the beginnings of the
Borg with the very first um mechanical
appliances and things like that where
they're slowly learning to evolve um and
take in technological aspects of other
races and other entities and things like
that um and of course um if they could
have done that then they could have
maybe shown a link to V and um and how
it was all done um I don't know I mean
like I said the Bor eventually made it
in Star Trek
uh was it first Contact the E movie um
but yeah I I don't know but it's it
definitely had some influences um which
again the Bor must have been influenced
even if it wasn't they weren't actually
connected the writers must have got part
of the idea from this partly you know
and also do Doctor Who Cyberman that was
also a reference to the Bor as well so
again again all these shows they go
around in circles they all link together
in some ways oh yeah B Tech or anti Borg
Tech I like that I love that idea I mean
that's I'd love to see them come back
Doom machine people I just think the um
did Kirk beat the Bor no he didn't Dave
not not as far as we know um I like the
idea that this was a weapon a living
weapon because also if you think about
it from like an assimilation point of
view that might explain the vast cloud
and stuff as well that it would
Encompass planet we saw um engulfing
another space station one of the
Federation stations it was literally it
was like it was literally it like it
eats it and then converts into data and
then it's stored in like a big kind of
memory
archive but sounds very Bing yeah I
suppose yeah I mean the Bor ass simulate
um technology and also yeah yeah that is
another bism I'm going with it as a
weapon there we go we've solved it
problem solved so it was a it was a
weapon yeah a borgan weapon for star
that's it so we' we've introduced the
world now that's it that's what it was
all about so there we go it was a Bor
weapon it was a sweet right we've
covered it next time in three or four
weeks when we get right into it we are
going to do the wrath of KH
KH yeah that'd be good that' be good no
um I watched this about a week ago so
I'm very excited and this is um we will
do it exactly the same way we will have
all of those ratings again and you'll
save the ones from this week and we'll
keep them on work we'll save it all and
we will have our points and at the end
when we get to Star Trek insurrection
that's gonna Point well um we
will a solution no that's not the last
film though is it I'm saying that's the
last film it's not um but anyway we will
have a final solution that would be are
we doing the Kellum films as well though
or we just doing yeah kin films and they
might not do very well either and some
of these ratings but they will do
they'll do well in
the so what it be four weeks people so
it'd be actually good and sort of build
it up and then over a year it'll take a
year to go through them all but that's
fine I'm not going anywhere so it be
fine so cool Jay thank you very much
it's been good F you're very welcome sir
um it's been an absolute joy as always
um again we're streaming on both
channels which is cool if you are
watching us on Sid trk please go there's
a link in the description to C clud and
go subscribe lots of funny clips and
things on there and vice versa please
check out
Sid Trek I'm a big fan some great
material anything sci-fi based um you
know it's great to P our
resources no go over and check out sty
trek. co.uk where we that's our de
website where we do articles on our
videos and things so and I it takes a
lot of time so please go and look at it
absolutely oh my God it takes a long
time so um yeah no thanks thanks Mikey
thank you very much talk to you have a
good one
bye bye